احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه
المقابله الخاصه مع ساعدت السفير السعودي
في كوريا الجنوبيه سامسه حان شكرا لك
سعاده السفير على استضافتك لنا على هامش
الزياره المرتقبه لولي العهد السعودي الى
كوريا الجنوبيه
لهذا اللقاء
وتغطياتكم لهذه الزياره المهمه
زياره سمو ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
حفظه الله
لدول الصناعيه تستشرف المستقبل بكل ثقه
بهدف اا تحويل الاقتصاد السعودي من
الاقتصاد مستهلك للتقنيه والصناعات الى
اقتصاد منتج لها همم
هناك اهتمام بالغ من
جمهوريه كوريا من المسؤولين والقطاع الخاص
وتحديدا من الرئيس الكوري بهذه الزياره
ونتمنى ان شاء الله
ان تحقق المزيد من التعاون في كافه
القطاعات
والمجالات
المستهدفه
وبشكل اعمق واوسع واشمل همم كوريا شريك
استراتيجي مهم همم في رؤيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه 20 30
وهناك لجنه
همم اللجنه السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 همم
كنت تعمل كما نصه لتطوير التعاون في هذه
المجالات اكثر من 40 مجال تستهدف هذه
اللجنه في قطاعات عديده الطاقه والتصنيع
الاستثمار البناء التحتيه والمدن الذكيه
المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه
والبنيه التحتيه كما كما اشررت اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث عن
العلاقه همم الكوريه السعوديه طبعا هي
علاقه قديمه اكثر من 60 عاما حتى في
السبعينات والثمانينات كان هناك العديد من
الكوريين ساهموا في البناء التحتيه وفي
الاعمال في السعوديه كيف يمكن ان نصفها
الان
ذكرتي العلاقات التاريخيه وقديمه يصادف
هذا العام مرور 60 عام على انشائها في عام
1962 همم منذ بدايه
والشركات الكوريه متواجده في المملكه عملت
على الكثير من المباني والانشاءات والبناء
التحتيه والموانئ ومن ذلك الوقت وحتى
وقتنا الحاضر وهي تنمو همم بشكل سريع
ومتطور اممم حتى
جاءت الزياره التي تعتبر نقطه التحول في
مسيره العلاقات زياره سمو ولي العهد في
عام 2019 همم
والتي انطلقت منها الوزاره العلاقات الى
شراكه استراتيجيه الحقيقه في كثير من
المجالات وبدات كما ذكرت لجنه الرؤيه ال
20 همم 30 المكونه بين السعوديه وجمهوريه
كوريا
لتفعيل همم هذا هذا التعاون الاستراتيجي
همم بين البلدين همم افق هذه هذه العلاقه
همم اراه انا شخصيا انه مليء بالتعاون
مليء بالتنسيق مليء بالفرص الاستثماريه
همم التي تقيمها الشركات السعوديه في
المشاريع الضخمه الموجوده في السعوديه
سواء في البتروكيميكو او في
الصناعات الاخرى ال- ال- ال- المتوسطه
فانا متفائل جدا
بمستقبل هذه العلاقات
ماذا يتحدث عن دور السفاره في همم
تسويق رؤيه 20 30 جذب الاستثمارات الكوريه
الى السعوديه وهل ترون حماس همم بان تقوم
هذه الشركات بفتح فروع لها في السعوديه
نعم هناك عمل جبار
تقوم به السفاره
وشركائها من وزاره التجاره وزاره
الاستثمار هيئه تنميه الصادرات
للتعريف بالفرص الاستثماريه التي موجوده
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتعرضها امام
همم القطاع الخاص والشركات الكوريه
المتواجده وهناك تعاون وهناك حماس
معالي وزير الاستثمار كان هنا قبل فتره
همم
كانوا اللقاءات واقيمه ورش عمل فقط هدفها
التعريف بالفرس الاستثماريه سوف يقام ايضا
منتدى الاستثمار على هامش هذه الزياره همم
لجذب الشركات
ورجال الاعمال همم في لقاء مباشر مع شركات
وهمم رجال اعمال سعوديين ليتم
بحث ومناقشه همم فرص الاستثمار في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لذلك هناك حماس كبير من
الشركات الكوريه في الدخول في شركات
استراتيجيه واستثماريه وتجاريه مع القطاع
الخاص بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن المبتعثين من
المعروف ان هناك عدد كبير من المبتعثين
المتواجدين في السعوديه همم هل لدينا
ارقام عددهم ابرز المجلات التي همم تفوق
بها الممتعه في السعودي في كوريا الجنوبيه
المجال التعليم والجامعات همم في كوريا
لها معيار عالي على مستوى العالم
وهناك مجموعه من الطلبه السعوديين في حدود
300 طالب متدرب وتدارس همم
يمثل اغلبيتهم اطباء وهذا شيء جيد ان
نستفيد من تجارب
والتطور العلمي في مجال في مجال الطب
ونطمح ان شاء الله ان يكون هناك زياده في
الاعداد
لتشمل باقي المجالات من صناعه وتحور رقمي
وتكنولوجيا همم
الذي تعتبر كوريا متطوره عالميا في هذا في
هذا المجال
ومؤخرنا اعتقد احدى همم احد الطلبه
السعوديين حصل على جائزه عالميه في مجال
الطب وهذا وهذا شيء جميل همم
ومشجع ببقيه الطلبه الاخرى للانضمام
للابتعاد لبرنامج الابتعاد في همم كوريا
الجنوبيه ولدينا ملحقيه ثقافيه حقيقه تشرف
على هذا البرنامج ودائما نحث همم الشركات
الكوريه بفتح ابواب للتدريب ونقل الخبرات
للطلبه السعوديين سواء المبتعثين او
الموجودين خارج كوريا وايضا هناك ملف همم
اكسبو 20 30 وابرز الدول المرشحه لاستضافه
هذا الحدث الكبير
بالاضافه طبعا الى العديد من الدول
السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه كيف يمكن ان نصف
هذا التنافس على هذا الملف
معرض اكسبو 20 30 معرض مهم للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ونسعد بقوه للفوز بهذا بتنظيم هذا الحدث
التنافس ما بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكوريا هو تنافس ما بين الاصدقاء
ان شاء الله ان ان ان ان تفوز المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بحدود حق تنظيم هذا
الهدف هذا الهدف العام للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
شكرا على حسن المتابعه